thought I would do some more example
problems involving triangles and so this
first one it says the measure of the
largest angle in a triangle is 4 times
the measure of the second largest angle
the smallest angle is 10 degrees what
are the measures of all the angles well
we know one of them we know it's 10
degrees let's draw an arbitrary triangle
right over here so let's say that is our
triangle we know that the smallest angle
is going to be 10 degrees and I'll just
say let's just assume that this right
over here is the measure of the smallest
angle it's 10 degrees now let's call the
second largest angle let's call that
let's call that X so the second largest
angle let's call that X so this is going
to be X and then the first sentence they
say the measure of the largest angle in
a triangle is 4 times 4 times the
measure of the second largest angle so
the second largest angle is X 4 times
that measure is going to be 4x so the
largest angle is going to be is going to
be 4x and so the one thing we know about
the measures of the angles inside of a
triangle is that they add up to 180
degrees so we know that 4 X plus X plus
X plus 10 degrees plus 10 degrees is
going to be equal to 180 degrees is
going to be equal to 180 + 4 X plus X
that just gives us 5x and then we have 5
X plus 10 is equal to 180 degrees
subtract 10 from both sides you get 5x
is equal to 170 and so X is equal to 170
over 5 and let's see it'll go into it
what is that 34 times let me verify this
so 5 goes into yeah it should be 34
times because it's going to go into
twice as many times as 10 would go into
it 10 would go into 170 17 times 5 we go
into hundred 70 34 times so we could
verify it went to 170 five goes into 17
3 times 3 times 5 is 15 subtract you get
to bring down the 0 5 goes into 20 four
times and then you're not going to have
a remain
four times five is 20 no remainder so
it's 34 times so X is equal to 34 so the
second largest angle has a measure of 34
degrees
this angle up here is going to be four
times that so four times 34 let's see
that's going to be 120 degrees plus 16
degrees this is going to be 136 degrees
is that right 4 times 4 times 4 is 16 4
times 3 is 120 16 plus 1 or Twenties 136
degrees so we're done the three measures
or the three the the sizes of the three
angles are 10 degrees 34 degrees and 136
degrees let's do another one so let's
see we have a little bit of a drawing
here and what I want to do is and we
could think about different things we
could say let's solve for X I'm assuming
that 4x is the measure of this angle 2x
is the measure of that angle right over
there we can solve for X and then if we
know X we can figure out what the actual
measures of these angles are assuming
that we can figure out X and the other
thing that they tell us is that this
line over here is parallel to this line
over here and was very craftily drawn
because it's parallel but they kind of
one stops here then one starts up there
so the first thing I wondered if they're
telling us these two lines are parallel
is probably going to be something
involved involving transversals or
something it might be something
involving the other option is something
involving triangles and at first you
might say wait are is this angle and
that angle vertical angles we have to be
very careful they are not this is not
the same line this this line is parallel
to that line it's not it's not this line
it's bending right over there so we
can't make any type of assumption like
that
so the interesting thing and I'm not
sure if this will lead in the right
direction is to just make it clear that
these two are these two are part of
parallel lines so I could continue this
line down like this and then I can can
you continue this line up like that and
then that starts to look a little bit
more like we're used to when we're
dealing with parallel lines and then
this line segment BC or we could even
say line BC if we were to continue it on
if we were to continue it on and on even
pass D then this is clearly a
transversal of those two parallel lines
this is clearly a transversal and so if
this angle right over here if this angle
right over here is 4x it has a
corresponding angle half of the or maybe
most of the work on all of these is to
try to see the parallel lines and see
the transversal and see see the one that
see the things that might be useful for
you so that right there is the
transversal these are the parallel lines
that's one parallel line that is the
other parallel you can almost try to
zone out all of the other stuff in the
diagram and so if this angle right over
here is 4 X it has a corresponding angle
on the other where the transversal
intersects the other parallel line this
right here is its corresponding angle so
let me draw it in that same yellow this
right over here is a corresponding angle
so this will also be this will also be
4x and we see that this angle this angle
and this angle this angle that has
measure 4x and this measure this angle
that measures 2x we see that they're
supplementary they're adjacent to each
other their outer their outer sides form
a straight angle so they're
supplementary which means that their
measures add up to 180 degrees they kind
of form they go all the way around like
that if you add the two adjacent angles
together so we know that 4x + 2 X needs
to be equal to 180 degrees or we get 6x
is equal to 180 degrees
divide both sides by 6 you get X is
equal to 30 or X is equal to well I
shouldn't say well X could be 30 and
then this angle right over here is 2
times X so it's going to be 60 degrees
so this angle right over here is going
to be 60 degrees and this angle right
over here is this angle right over here
is 4 times X so it is it is 120 degrees
and we're done